je veux dire je veux dire amis à mes
amis gilet jaune et moi savent que je
les soutiens de la première heure que
l'interpellation dont il a été victime
non mais c'est justement lorsque vous
dire parce que moi je me souviens plus
je laisse ça je suis acheté d'occasion
bien d'accord mais maintenant ce que je
vois c'est que vous êtes du côté des
puissants
c'est que mon dicton qui dit mais oui
vous êtes du côté des puissants et ça
vous pouvez pas lié quand on prend toute
la journée et la nuit je ne peux rien y
ait dans vos accusations
je ne peux rien c'est vrai à sion mais
voilà c'est pour ça que je ne peux pas
dire ce que les gilets jaunes sondhi ou
7 la vérité monsieur est ce que tout ce
que je vais vous vous êtes du côté du
mensonge et la manipulation tout ce que
vous dites est vrai voilà tout ce que je
dis moi il faut voilà alors toi pourquoi
c'est pourquoi je voulais que un moment
donné on termine sur ça parce que je
pense que ce qu'on vient de voir dans
tous nous mettre d'accord mais sont pas
pour reiss et d'un match je viens de
dire nous tous nous mettre d'accord ça
c'est inacceptable c'est l'inquisition
c'est tout ce qu'on n'a pas le droit de
voir dans notre pays et c'est mes coups
plus fréquents que je le croyais oui
mais monsieur parlait mais c'est pas
parce que s'ils seront créés dans la
scellier et des préjugés les voilà là
c'est vraiment les préjugés mais quand
je dis attendez moi je vais là dessus il
ya deux choses
il ya là là ce qu'on entend parce que
moi j'ai vu cette vidéo sur les réseaux
sociaux et je digère jeu tout de suite
marqué j'ai dit mais des crétins comme
ça décrédibilise notre mouvement
exactement donc ça et voilà un accord
par contre par contre là dessus il n'y a
pas que l'attaqué contre les
journalistes
il ya aussi il a parlé de votre il a dit
vous êtes des millionnaires vous tiriez
millionnaire donc ce qui hélas
vous savez je vais vous dire que je
raconte la magie excusez moi la magie
c'est quelque chose qui a été
exceptionnel c'est le fait que le peuple
invisible met un gilet jaune pour
devenir visibles mais aujourd'hui on
voit aussi que ça a ses limites parce
que quelle que soit la personne qui dit
je suis j'ai les jeunes ça y est on dit
il et gilet jaune
moi je vais vous dire la première heure
dans les gilets jaunes il y avait des
artisans il y avait des commerçants il y
avait des entrepreneurs il y avait des
chômeurs etc
moi j'ai aucun problème est que les
riches d'accord moi je
heureux que dans ce pays a des gens qui
réussissent parce qu'ils se sont donnés
le mal pour réussir moi je suis dit il
faut que ça ruisselle comment je suis
leurs responsabilités ceux qui ont rogné
pas plus parce qu'ils ont un rôle dans
la société
je trouve que ça c'est ridicule parce
que ça ça veut dire que quelqu'un qui
réussit dans le pays il doit être tout
de suite pointé du doigt non quelqu'un
qui réussit dans le pays il doit être un
exemple il doit lui-même s'imposait être
à un exemple et reste et se
responsabiliser et que l'état les
responsabilise aussi agathe voulu réagir
à tuer après je vais demander à jean
michel aphatie
voilà j'ai quality ces réactions après
oui bien sûr et là ou là où je vous
rejoins c'est effectivement dans tous
les sondages ou baromètre d'opinion ces
dernières années le métier de
journalisme et le métier journée s'est
toujours classé parmi les plus détestés
les points les prises et où cela
fonction qui inspire le moins de
confiance possible donc la haine
vis-à-vis de la presse elles datent pas
de gilet jaune elle a toujours existé
mais ce à quoi je pense on assiste
depuis là un certain temps c'est une
véritable fracture médiatique parce que
précisément la genèse de ce mouvement
elle est née sans aucun intermédiaire
sans aucun média ils sont nés des
réseaux sociaux et même aujourd'hui moi
je vois dans mon comportement
quand je recherche d'informations quand
je veux savoir ce qui se passe les
samedis de manifestations je tape des
hashtags sur twitter et je vais voir ce
qui se passe sur twitter et les vidéos
qui sont relayés par les gens sur le
terrain et je vais plus ouvrir la presse
je vais plus écouter la radio ou quoi
que ce soit parce que ben oui c'est ça
et je pense qu'il ya une véritable
fracture médiatique parce qu'en plus les
doctes un point de vue du gilet jaune et
pour avoir beaucoup parlé avec eux soit
le journaliste est à la botte de macron
et sert la soupe du gouvernement soit il
est dans une tentative de les
décrédibiliser et de ne mettre en avant
que les côtés sombres pour pour servir
son métier pour servir sa chaîne etc
le dialogue n'est plus possible je pense
entre jean michel tu traction là dessus
parce que moi je suis fier même envoyé
un sms
non mais franchement j'ai trouvé mon
rythme comportement de jean michel
aphatie
[Applaudissements]
je sors dans la rue il ya quelqu'un qui
dit mon nom est donc je comprends que
c'est quelqu'un qui a envie de parler
assez vite quoi qu'il ya envie de parler
du bien sûr du traitement des journées
je vois qu'ils me filme mais moi la
vérité parce que j'aime parler du jour
ne sait ce qu'on voit ce que j'aime
expliquer une chose
j'aime dire que moi dans ma tête je suis
tout seul j'attends pas que ma chaîne
m'appelle de l'elysée qu'est ce que tu
vas dire demain sur la non pas ça moi et
j'ai envie d'expliquer ça j'ai envie
d'expliquer comment je fais mon métier
parce que je pense que la manière donc
je fais mon métier et la manière dont
une immense majorité des journalistes en
france font leur métier
nous avons une véritable alors peut-être
qu'on fait des erreurs mais nous avons
une véritable liberté et donc j'ai voulu
et l'expliquer à cette personne qui
qu'il voulait des informations alors
après le dialogue évolué parce qu'en
fait ils demandent plus comment je
travaille il me met en cause de moi donc
ça n'a plus aucun intérêt
bon là après on s'est embarqué dans une
discussion jusqu'à la quenelle qui était
bête mais aussi souvent qu'on le peut à
mon avis on doit expliquer comment on
travaille alors peut-être qu'on me
travaillait pas bien donc travailler
librement
mais est-ce que ça il faudrait quand
même longtemps juge jean-michel est ce
que vous comprenez voilà qui est de plus
en plus de journalisme de personnages
publics mais il a pu l'interpeller
bernard tapie qui sont interpellés comme
ça et qu'ils sont filmés même ans et
agressif ne l'était pas il faut pas
encourager ça d'ailleurs presque
personne ne lui répond pour sa wii passe
pas parce que moi je suis quelquefois
dans la rue comme si on me dit où je
pars quoi bon mais là vous avez gagné en
sympathie
parce que oui mais c'était pas calculés
sur les réseaux sociaux pas car il
savait sur les réseaux sociaux il ya
quasiment je me joue aucun comme on en
voit la patte si vous avez téva pourrait
croire que tout ça est organisée
ce que la pâte y viser tout ça ces
jeunes avaient jeté un sort
et c'est vrai que je trouve j'ai pas
irrite moscou est vraiment tous ici je
trouve qu'il a eue pour que brad et self
control sionnel maintenant sur l'idée
c'est d'expliquer serait-ce que bernard
laporte il y aura peut-être d'autres
voies larges et on peut pas diriger des
gens qui volent des images dans la rue
avant ce terme est lâché ce type
d'attitude ça c'est vrai